[Music]
now we talked a little bit about uh
about the Harley
um Harley Quinn yeah she dated the Joker
no no this person is way more evil
this person is observably more evil evil
Harley Pasternak who we brought up
remember Kanye had that
posted that screenshot of a text he had
and now Harley Harley Pasternak is that
trainer to the Stars yeah the personal
trainer dude who helps out all those
cool stars that all of which seem to
always have some huge life-changing
things that happen yeah always
um
well it's weird he lists Krav Maga is
like one of his [ __ ] classes but he
never teaches it yeah here check this
out
Ah that's mental Krav Maga
um
this is
the guy that does this is the guy that I
do my workout routine with and then he
also tells me when I'm trans yes which
turns out is always
um so this is uh the only mainstream
media site I saw cover this on November
9
16 a week and a half after Donald Trump
won the presidential election
Kanye West now known as yay held a
concert in Sacramento most people in the
audience were of course young people and
presumably Hillary Clinton voters and
presumably deeply disappointed by her
loss a week and a half before
so in the middle of the show west stop
performing started talking about
politics Google lied to you he said by
suggesting to its users that Hillary was
going to win quote Facebook lied to you
I'm not here to massage you with a fake
truth telling you that Hillary's going
to win I remember and over and over you
were lied to by Google you were lied to
by Mark Zuckerberg Middle America West
continued showed you how they felt
well at this point some of the audience
began to boo but West kept going he
complimented Donald Trump repeatedly at
one point he used the phrase make
America great again
it was to put it mildly not the kind of
thing you normally hear at a rap concert
and then two days later Kanye West was
in the hospital let the house of his
family's exercise trainer a man called
Harley Pasternak West apparently
suffered some kind of mental break
Pasternak called an ambulance to pick
him up West was taken away and then Pat
keep in mind this is stuff that you did
really I didn't really think
pasture neck is the one to call for the
ambulance yeah it was at his house that
this meltdown happened and he was
sedated with at least seven different
psychiatric medications including
benzodiazepines lithium sleeping pills
and olanzapine or as Jordan Peterson
calls it breakfast
I call that a bloody appetizer
news reports suggested that West had
experienced a profound psychiatric
episode he'd gone completely off the
deep end he'd gone crazy and they've
been saying that ever since
West over time though told a very
different story in his telling after
what he'd said on stage in Sacramento a
Harley pasternack was trying to shut him
up
Pastor Knack he said was not simply a
trainer but instead an agent of
ideological control Pastor not's job is
to keep West from straying from the
script and he's willing to use powerful
drugs to do it that's what he said but
very few people took that claim
seriously in fact it was exactly the
kind of thing a crazy person would say
my trainer drugged me into submission
but he used to think Kanye had the as
they say the receipts and he's trying to
make me into a zombie
right sure he did have another
olanzapine shot Kanye you look tired so
that's where the story stood until the
other day nobody believes Kanye West
then West posted something remarkable on
Twitter which for some reason virtually
all of American Media ignored which is
because it wasn't about the Jews it's
odd because media Outlets are not
usually in the business of ignoring
remarkable things but they did and what
he posted was a picture of a text
exchange that he had had with Harley
Pasternak
Mr Knack was explaining that West had
better stopped saying quote crazy stuff
in other words he'd better get back on
script or else he would be severely
punished quote second option if you
don't shut up quote I have you
institutionalized again where they
medicate the crap out of you and you go
back to Zombieland forever play date
with the kids just won't be the same
end quote
that's dark super dark can to imagine a
more Sinister threat than that a more
chilling threat than that do what I say
or I will turn your brain to Mush I will
destroy your relationship with your own
children I will send you back to quote
Zombieland forever effectively I'll kill
you
now keep in mind this is from West's
quote trainer and that's the why it's
bro
Hollywood people they all need a trainer
right so it's the greatest cover to have
the oh he's my nutritionist in trainer
he's you know
because who's ever really gonna follow
up on that like who's this guy oh he
does all my nutrition my training and
stuff oh okay okay
not his position this is the guy he'd
hired to help him do squats
a trainer really did they talk like that
at your gym
probably not well some of them I've seen
some pretty intense ones yeah like not
usually they don't threaten to drug you
but they they will retina I will [ __ ]
kill you if you'll get one more rep
let's [ __ ] go I will murder your
family and then you do it and they're
like good job bud good job pal any plans
this weekend wait to push it bro yeah
any plans this weekend so what's going
on here exactly well according to his
bio Harley Pasternak who is not denied
writing these texts once worked for the
Canadian military where he participated
in experiments that measured the effect
of various drugs on the human mind oh
yeah no that's he's like MK Ultra guy
like openly Canadian mkl tree
is that training relevant to this story
we don't know
we do know that based on this text
exchange which again Harley Pasternak
has not said is untrue or fake on the
basis of that law enforcement agencies
definitely ought to be looking very
closely at Harley pasternack who by the
way apparently has dozens of other
celebrities they would but they don't
want to damage government property for
the clients some of whom seem to be out
there campaigning
based on these texts this looks like a
crime
why is no one investigating it the fact
that no one is well because of the Jew
stuff it's the Jew stuff mostly the Jew
stuff it's the juice stuff now that's
Harley pastry now I I was like well
I've never really for somebody who's
such a famous star I've never really
heard of him this famous trainer to the
Stars excuse me you figure like you'd
hear about them so I did a Google Search
and I didn't look for this on purpose
this is one of the third thing that
popped up
laughs
I'll just play it
Michael you're getting a five minute
workout I am so in well you come on over
Ginger because it is time now for our
series fast fixes for 29. no Michael are
you one of them
no my theory you ready for my theory
Stephanopoulos again is trying to go I'm
gonna get my hooks in them and this will
calm them down look at that give me that
pasternet guy you know the guy that we
went to when we when I worked for Obama
that took these guys out the problem is
it's Michael Strahan so what you're
going to train somebody who's literally
lives in the gym like you know what I
mean and he's gonna be like so what are
you saying let me let me ask you a
question Holly what you're saying is I
got to work on my tricep extension and
not talk bad about the Jews I can't do
both
I just like he'll be like hey yeah
Michael help uh train you sometime no
it's okay I'm good
powering over him not five the juice the
juice
I got a Peloton in my house I don't even
need to really go to any gym
and this morning is all about Fitness my
man here Harley pathanaki the fitness
burial in the best-selling author of the
body reset diet and you have a five it
really is hilarious how they built this
entire fake infrastructure around these
people like Harley past like they built
like they'll either give you a book
you'll get a little so you have like a
profile and you have some things there
go on Good Morning America yeah yeah
have a book that nobody bought but it's
out it's there it existed they work out
and also here's the other thing about
him he doesn't even look he's in great
shape he looks like he's in okay shape
he just is like a runner like a skinny
Runner right also Frozen is that you
Frozen is that you on the left there no
okay you can pretty much do it even you
set your muscles I think that it just
doesn't even need to be males it's just
any Asian person it's frozen yeah
absolutely and this is the beginning of
the year 2019 people make excuses I
can't get to the gym I don't have lots
of equipment I don't have the time today
I'm going to show you how to take five
of my favorite exercise sizes combine
them into and if you don't do them I'm
going to drug you and separate you from
your children
and I'm gonna have people pick you up in
the middle of the night put a black bag
over your head and take you to a black
site prison but I feel like knowing
straight hand like some Mr Magoo thing
it's like the Wiley Coyote he keeps
trying to inject him and he keeps
missing and hitting himself or falling
over because Strahan's like oh a penny
Falls over
alternate every other day five minutes
you're done so five that's what we said
five minutes you can be done five
minutes you can be done all right so the
first people here they're all doing five
different exercises the first thing
we're gonna do is a bent over row really
a simple movement reaching down all the
way she's squeezing from her shoulder
blades right up here really great upper
back exercise then we see terrible bent
over row so we'll start with that and
again it's so it's 2019 right so you can
see this is a guy who has been who's
being set up
being pushed
my opinion by some sort of three-letter
agency which one it is I'm not sure it
might it doesn't even have to be an
American one maybe it's more than one
maybe it's a conglomerate we have a
stiff leg deadlift a really great
movement for the hamstrings the butt the
lower back okay both of these pull the
body back create the illusion of having
a longer leaning leaner physique and we
can combine both well like an illusion
that black people actually run the rap
industry I was talking to my friend
Kanye and he told me not to trust you
yeah what do you mean by that my good
friend Kanye West woman asked if you
could give him his Masters back
also he said I'm going by the name hand
now
you're going to combine both of these
also what's DEFCON mean
both of us right here okay we're gonna
grab these dumbbells
first off
Michael Strahan is humongous and you're
keeping him little [ __ ] ing dumbbells
he's giving him the dumbbells that old
ladies hold when they walk around the
mall
at the pink one so you go Mike no try to
keep up
okay you're gonna get in position we're
gonna throw your hips back like a
deadlift when you're I'm telling you I
keep thinking as Looney Tunes he's gonna
swing his arm out and just knock him out
by mistake no let's take these tiny
little pink weights and uh Hey listen
former NFL defensive player of the year
I want you to try to keep up all right
ah keep up when you said that he's doing
all of this stuff just thinking back of
Lawrence Taylor I was thinking about I
was [ __ ] laughing with myself the
other day this is all a point it's all
this is all it is I did it without crack
Lawrence Checkmate you haven't you ever
been to space [ __ ] I just need a polar
bear now I think so all right you're
gonna do a row back down and then back
up
all Phil fix I would knock them out
they're back down row reach and back up
so if we were to do this for a minute
and then a minute off a minute a minute
off in a minute that's five minutes
you'll have yeah I get it but
this Lex Luthor looking guy
is getting into [ __ ] these people's
ears and they're [ __ ] with them and I
will agree this is the thing you know he
hasn't denied that text message either
he was not just really weird yeah that's
five minutes you'll have three sets you
will be attired your hamstrings your
back your everything's tired already
let's move on
okay what we got next now we've got
seated clam shells or abductions
that's not what you call a woman
that's no way to speak of a lady yeah
like like it implies that her entire
existence is just her body is just a
shell to protect her clams the gag
listen here clam shell
hey Frozen you're Asian do you do you do
seated seated clam shells
no
that's why your vagina's so loose didn't
even know shouldn't we use a hip Circle
you can get these online for two hours
the rubber ones this is a fancier one I
wrote she's telling you about the sex
dolls did you get one of those Asian sex
dolls my name with a marker on it so no
one steals it after the show and this
hits the glute medius which is the
outside of the hip
um really important muscle for balance
stability and rounds out the side of the
butt then we have a hip thrust yeah
sorry did you did you hear somebody
audibly say wow wow
what are you wearing
simple movement to do lying on the
ground driving up through your heels and
keeping your shoulder blades down this
is yeah I'm familiar with this exercise
I never do it at the gym because you
look silly
you haven't done it in the bedroom
either for a while
Brady over here doing exercise no it's
the taebo guy Harley hired him and took
him under his wing
the big pay is there a way we could get
Harley pastern egg to [ __ ] go find
Mark Harley and they have a little a
little tag team podcast yeah or you
think we'd get Harley past Nick to meet
up with uh big gay lion and Drug him and
lock him away forever and put him in
Zombieland wherever that is he already
is he's in thick
as we call it Zombieland
part of the butt and the hamstrings
right
and last but not least we have a lying
dumbbell tricep extension you can do
this on that is this woman come with the
workout am I allowed to conquer her like
they did in Game of Thrones
on the ground you can do it on the bench
and it's a simple movement that hits the
back of the arm or the triceps you don't
need any help yes I do but you're gonna
it's weird and like she looks like she's
doing some kind of upside down hand job
I remember this did happen one time when
I visited the Minnesota Vikings in one
of them boats
remember that one though the [ __ ] the
the poor boat that they had behind me
right over here on the ground so all
three of these on the ground I'm doing
gimmicks his whole life yeah
head down here if you don't mind we're
going to throw the hip Circle over your
legs just put it above the knee now for
those he's so strong it just snaps it's
just
now because if you're at home again
because he stretched it so far it like
rubber bands into the audience
it shoots him out the window no it hits
Stephanopoulos [ __ ] God damn it oh
simple piece of equipment you can get it
online and grab the two dumbbells we're
gonna start off with your arms up to the
ceiling okay but how are you gonna pick
those two women up
and your hips up to the ceiling this is
the starting position from here we're
going to lower the dumbbells and hips at
the same time hips and everything up
perfect so we're hitting triceps we're
hitting butt we're hitting all the
things bro you could punch like you used
to be able to it's like 500 pounds why
are you doing this mom workout [ __ ]
things you need how does it feel it
feels great I wanted to get how long am
I supposed to do this a minute
peace I love child and some people were
saying like oh yeah all the the Tran
stuff and this and that that he had but
now looking back at like when he had
like the trans kid I think he's just so
dumb as a now you telling me Nash you
sure that little girl got a little that
little boy look I get that he's just an
idiot that does what he's told I'm not
asking for him to look I can't do that
thing anymore where you're like I hate
him because he's a lib [ __ ] like I don't
care man like I just want to goof on
people and have fun and like
anybody recover that's famous is going
to be some puppet of these people anyway
that's a good point I just like Strahan
because he's a big dumb idiot
he's so much fun yeah he's so much fun
to cover
all right we can move on